ein heruntergekommenes viertel irgendwo
in budapest die roma gelten selbst unter
den armen noch als unterschicht als
ausgestoßene victorias leben ist ohne
jede perspektive
wiener walzer heißt der zug der budapest
in nur zwölf stunden mit zürich
verbindet
der straßenstrich verspricht das
schnelle geld
das gleiche setting ein anderer film
traumland für geschätzte 25.000 frauen
die in der schweiz als prostituierte
arbeiten war dieses land einmal ihr
traumland dieser film erzählt die
geschichte von mir einer bulgarischen
prostituierten ihre lebenswelt steht in
krassem kontrast der postkarten idylle
ihres traumland diese parallelwelt hat
die regisseurin petra volpe interessiert
und fasziniert dadurch kann man keine
vorstellung was die den passiert papiere
kosteten sie im frauen- und man könnte
ihnen aber die frauen sind sie nicht
mehr die hand und sagt immer ganz viel
handlicher gerechnet hatten und haben
immer das machen die mit einer
handlichen und ich hatte eine zeit lang
6 telefon geschafft als studentin und
wenn mir das also gefragt was passiert
und stadt hinter deiner art zeigen
sieben einfachen das hat mich auch immer
sex und käuflicher sex und alles hat
mich schon immer sehr interessiert
der käuflichen sex ist das verbindende
element der beiden filme aber ihr fokus
unterscheidet sie der film victoria ist
ganz aus der perspektive der titelheldin
erzählt und bleibt in dieser
parallelwelt die der unsrigen so nah und
doch unendlich fern ist einer ihrer
freier fährt zufällig am zürichsee
vorbei
viktoria teilt ihre absteige mit einer
frau die schon seit jahren in zürich
arbeitet der film traumland konzentriert
sich dagegen mehr auf unsere welt wie
wir sie kennen die welt der alten der
einsamen der unter liebesentzug
leitenden derjenigen die für sex
bezahlen
es gibt ganz viel um verdrängte schmerz
und es kommt ganz film um einsamkeit und
um hoffnung und um bedürfnis nach nähe
und liebe und und nochmal anderen
menschen aber mehr mit filmischer
versucht sie wagt findet wie toaster
komfortzonen gute zahlen und dass am
ende in den film erzählt wo er sie gott
also ich verstehe einfach den reiz davon
nicht jemand mausarm dafür zu bezahlen
du verstehst du den reiz
traumland spielt an heiligabend in lose
zusammenhängenden episoden erzählt er
von unschönen bescherungen rund um die
käufliche liebe ein umgekehrter
weihnachtsfilm für den zuschauer wird
traumland fragen auf was ich mich halt
ich zur prostitution ich glaube schon
was fühle ich mich einzelne bezieht kann
ich mich mit einer figur identifizieren
bin ich aus seinen freien was würde ich
machen wenn wir diese finden mit marco
zu prostituierten würde bliebe würde die
klinik auch victoria die titelheldin des
zweiten films geht am ende zurück nach
budapest arm wie vorher
und nun noch um ein traumland